hey guys my name is Jeff today it is
februari the eleventh Andy is what
mattered in gaming today a slew of
release windows were revealed by Ubisoft
today including the announcement that a
sequel to watch dogs will be coming
before april of next year the
announcement was made as part of UV
third-quarter financial report where the
publisher said ubisoft will launch a
very high-quality lineup including for
honor southpark of the fractured
butthole Tom Clancy's Ghost Recon
wildlands and the next installment of
watchdogs basically that means all of
these games will launch before the end
of their next financial year in April
2017 they also added that they're
planning to launch a new high potential
triple-a bread with the strong digital
life services although at the moment we
have absolutely no idea what that might
be in other Ubisoft news the company
have confirmed that there will not be a
new main line Assassin's Creed game this
year cheering an earnings call you b
sub-ceo Eve Gilliam are confirmed that
there won't be a major AC release this
year to allow Ubisoft time to quote take
advantage of all the new technologies
you be also noted that this move does
not mean that the Assassin's Creed
series is moving to a biannual basis
they added in a blog post since the
release of Assassin's Creed unity we've
learned a lot based on your feedback
we've also updated our development
processes and recommitted to making
Assassin's Creed a premiere open-world
franchise we're taking this year to
evolve the game mechanics and to make
sure we're delivering on the promise of
Assassin's Creed offering unique and
memorable gameplay experiences that make
history everyone's playground if you
still need that Assassin's Creed fix the
three games that make up the assassin's
creed chronicles series plus the AC
movie starring Michael Fassbender are
all out this year so you should be set
elsewhere in the call it was noted that
Assassin's Creed syndicate did not
perform as well as Ubisoft expected but
Rainbow six siege was reporting record
player engagement levels
finally it's been announced that xbox
one title quantum break will be coming
to PC as well on the same day developer
Remedy Entertainment also revealed that
those who ordered the digital version of
quantum break for Xbox one will get a
free copy of the windows 10 edition
remedy have confirmed that the pc
version is being made in house and drop
the minimum and recommended specs which
you can check out on gamespot the game
supports cross saving between platforms
but not cross-platform play on top of
that the xbox one version will include a
copy of remedies last game Alan Wake and
both it's DLC add-on while pre-ordering
the xbox one version at some retailers
will also give place access to the
expansion alan wake's american nightmare
if you still don't have an xbox one
there's also a quantum break xbox one
bundle that you can get your hands on
which also comes boxed with our own wake
fly me know down in that comment section
if you're keen for quantum break and be
sure to have two games well we've got
stories on titanfall 2 action figures
and made the speed / pacing that is
everything I have for you today we do
join the same time tomorrow for the five
biggest stories of the entire week I
will catch you then